I feel like I have no skills to offer
anyway okay so if you're trapped in the
middle of nowhere Ellen may not be your
best bet at survival but in this
post-apocalyptic thriller into the
forest she's doing everything she can to
stay alive this is all we have we have
each other do you ask yourself those
questions when you're shooting it as you
guys are doing it what would I do in
this situation would you have acted the
same way I'd like to think so um but you
know they're pretty extraordinary what
they what they do in this film and so is
Ellen she not only stars in the movie
but she developed and produced it as
well what does that process for you
getting into this sort of aspect of
filmmaking for the first time for me it
was a tremendous opportunity because
I've been wanting to get you know to
start producing more projects and and I
worked with wonderful people who were
patient and taught me a lot why don't I
have a signal
okay there's no water either there's
nothing I'm just as reliant on the phone
and the technology and the comfort come
on you're pretty good with a knife now
no let's not go into it Ellen's also
pretty good at staying tight-lipped
especially when it comes to her next
high profile project the remake of
flatliners excuse me I don't want to
ruin anybody's evening when we remember
the dead man i'm not sure what I'm
supposed to say or not say or what have
you what can you say Oh making flatline
yeah he died in the movie no I mean I'm
not you know doesn't everybody died in
flatliners don't know they're okay sorry
everybody